we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to David P this is another
voicemail about me texting people just a
reminder these are scams I'm not texting
anybody
yeah I got one of your checks saying
call me direct message right away but no
I don't have the internet I don't have a
computer I got off that damn petrolic
internet platform stuff four years ago
well good for you I do listen to show
and dollar more
and I'll read the stuff that comes up on
YouTube yeah so listen this this I feel
bad for this guy there are people on
YouTube and because there's hundreds and
hundreds we report them as quickly as we
can okay but they keep popping up
they put my face in their profile
picture
and then they respond to YouTube
comments and go hey love the comment
could you text me or Whatsapp me or DM
me or whatever the case may be
I love everybody but I am not trying to
text any of you these are scams they
will try to steal your money okay report
them to YouTube for impersonation we
report them as well I feel bad
it's we're I'm not I'm too busy to text
with people okay I'm not even texting my
friends back because I'm so busy I'm not
trolling my own YouTube comments looking
for people to text so it is not me at
some point there will be a scam at the
end of the rainbow at some point they'll
try to take money from you or something
I don't even really know what the scam
is on the bonus show today folks very
good news Brittany Greiner has been
released by Russia this was a
one-for-one prisoner swap for arms
dealer Victor bout there are people
saying this was not a fair trade that
this was crazy to release Victor about
okay we will talk about it secondly
we're going to talk about the Indonesian
sex ban what does that mean and what
does it mean for producer Pat who will
join me on the bonus show and thirdly
we're going to talk about the real
reason that Iran says it's canceling the
morality police what yes all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up at joinpakman.com oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad beautifully set I'll
see you on the bonus show we're back
here tomorrow